there's been a lot of talk about the
bitcoin community bitcoin maximus what's
good what's bad and there's been plenty
and plenty of opinions that have floated
around the internet i recently saw lynn
alden with a great thread that i thought
was worth calling out she stated in her
tweets bitcoiners are a polarizing group
among broader twitter but it's actually
a great set of people for the most part
when you get to know the ecosystem and
the various individuals they are
disagreeable and aggregate but
principled meanwhile she continues to
see one thing the bitcoin price goes up
and it goes down but that orange line
right there that's the number of bitcoin
wallet addresses on chain with at least
.01 bitcoin
people continue to stack sats regardless
of what people say on the internet or
what the price of bitcoin does
lin then continues and says there are
loud uninformed social media individuals
and periodic waves of group think but
that happens in any space plenty of
individuals push back on that when it
happens truth is there is no bitcoin
community it's a group of many very
different subcultures there are og
cypherpunks developers libertarians
conservatives progressive entrepreneurs
vcs miners self-styled plebs analysts
scam breakers etc some of the biggest
forces in bitcoin aren't even active on
twitter or they are anonymous
only within the bitcoin community has
she seen anarchist conservative aligned
carnivores be close friends with
progressive libertarian vegans in person
and they rush to get a taxi together in
the rain there's something unique here
something powerful modern tribes are
flexible the reason why i think this
perspective is so good is because
ultimately this is the vision of the
internet is that people from all around
the world regardless of race sex creed
wealth status education language or
anything else can come together and talk
about ideas and push the world forward
the bitcoin community or those various
subcultures they continue to put their
heads down and push the world forward
some people agree with that future some
people don't but the beauty is that the
free market will ultimately determine
where value is created and where value
flows
so far bitcoin has grown from zero
dollars of market cap to hundreds of
billions of dollars in about 13 years it
has permeated individuals organizations
corporations
and now we even see nation states
ultimately folks from the midwest to
wall street to silicon valley to the
southeast of asia to europe to south
america into various countries in africa
everyone in the world with an internet
connection can access bitcoin can store
economic value and can transact
without relying on a trusted third party
it's a very powerful idea and as we all
know
there's nothing that stops an idea once
it's time has come
seeing lynn talk about the various
people in the bitcoin community like
this is encouraging we should all be
optimists we're all working towards the
same vision we're all working towards
the same goal
and we're going to need everyone's help
it's a hard problem to take a long time
to solve and i'm glad that you all are
here with me and everyone else trying to
make it happen